The Very Hungry Caterpillar by Eric Carle.
For my sister Crista.
In the light of the moon, a little egg lay on a leaf.
One Sunday morning, the warm sun came up...
...and popped out of the egg came a tiny and very hungry caterpillar.
He started to look for some food.
On Monday, he ate through one apple.
But he was still hungry.
On Tuesday, he ate through two pears.
On Wednesday, he ate through three plums.
But he was still hungry.
On Thursday, he ate through four strawberries.
On Friday, he ate through five oranges.
But he was still hungry.
On Saturday, he ate through: one piece of chocolate cake, one ice cream cone,...
...one pickle, one slice of Swiss cheese, one slice of salami,...
...one lollipop, one piece of cherry pie, one sausage,...
...one cupcake, and one slice of watermelon.
That night, he had a stomachache.
The next day was Sunday again.
The caterpillar ate through one nice green leaf.
And after that, he felt much better.
Now, he wasn't hungry anymore.
And he wasn't a little caterpillar anymore.
He was a big, fat caterpillar.
He built a small house, called a cocoon, around himself.
He stayed inside for more than two weeks.
Then, he nibbled a hole in the cocoon,...
...pushed his way out and...
...he was a beautiful butterfly.